[Music]
is that going to fit everyone
easily 12 customers total how do they
turn a profit 12.50 ahead that's how
what are we eating a roblox
it's one of his classics
you have to try the mouse feel of the
minute please don't say mouthful tonight
will be madness
welcome
we'll endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to hawthorne
here we are family
we harvest we ferment
we jowl
[Music]
we gel
he's not just a chef he's a storyteller
the game is trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
gonna be
you won't know until the end
who are you i
am margo
how do you care i have to know if you're
with us
or with them
this menu the pictures they're of us
this guest list
how do they get these it's not good
this entire evening
this is crazy this is just theater it's
stagecraft we're leaving now
has been painstakingly planned
this is real isn't it
what the hell is going on
we now offer you a 45 second head start
okay 45 seconds starts now
this is what you're paying for
step out of their way
it's all part of the menu
it's okay no we're gonna die
[Music]
birthday to
you
you told him it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
[Music]
foreign